right what i want to talk about today is
do things touch do atoms touch do
molecules touch when i bring my hands
together are they actually touching or
are they repelling there's zom quite a
lot on the internet and in the physics
forums and the chemistry forums and in
reddit and a range of other forum
about this question so it's pretty close
to my heart because what
arrived in my
inbox yesterday my mailbox was this so
this is my field of research non-contact
atomic force microscopy the thing that
puzzles me is if things never really
contact each other
why do we draw a distinction between
non-contact and contact atomic force
microscopy what is that distinction so
there is such thing as contact atomic
force microscopy there is indeed there's
contact mode and there's non-contact
mode and i tell the first-year students
about this a lot and they actually a
number of them have referred to this um
discussion on the internet so we'll
actually you know particularly in the
first couple of weeks when they come in
just you are aware you're holding a cup
of tea
sorry
just let me just take one more slug of
it now put it over here stupid it's even
closer to my heart because at the moment
i've been working on this paper all over
the last couple of weeks where we do
what we called and others before us have
called point contact probe microscopy
notice the word contact we go back to
1986 the inventors of the scanning
tuning microscope and the atomic force
microscope so these are two tools that
allow us to see in not only individual
atoms but the state of the artist to see
individual bonds and i've waffled at
length about these in previous videos
just because you use the word doesn't
automatically mean it's happening the
important thing is we can have a very
rigid definition of what contact means
and the problem is with the discussions
some of the discussions on the internet
the the argument seems to be here's one
atom well let's call it a molecule
here's one molecule here's another
molecule the problem with a lot of the
discussions is that well you bring these
molecules together you bring them
together and then they start to repel
that's wrong
that's that's that's fundamentally wrong
that's not what happens you bring two
molecules together even if they don't
form a chemical bond they attract it's
something called the van der waals force
and the
where it originates from is that you've
got electrons over here you've got
electrons over here quantum mechanics
tells us that we don't pin those
electrons down to a particular location
so they're fluctuating here and they're
fluctuating here that means that on and
very
small fractions of time
you're getting dipoles you're getting a
charge a slight charge imbalance and
that's slight charge and balance over
here and that slight charge imbalance
over here gives rise to an attractive
force and that's really important if
long before you get to the repulsive
side you have an attractive force
where we can define contact very easily
is at the point where that attractive
force is balanced by the repulsive force
and those discussions on the interior
are quite correct there is a repulsive
force and it's ultimately due to
something called the pauli exclusion
principle which basically well
let's not go into the whole details of
the pauli exclusion principle lots of
videos and 60 symbols about that we have
a very well defined position at which
the net force the balance of the
repulsive and the attractive
contributions is zero
and that actually defines
the bond length or defines the
intermolecular separation if we don't
have a chemical bond but we do not need
a sharing of electrons we do not need an
exchange of an electrons this van der
waals force which is everywhere around
us the typical example is how does the
gecko stick everywhere and it's due to
the fan ultimately due to this founder
of old's force so let me point out two
things get those balls where you had
them
let me point out two things you've just
done there
first of all you've made a big point of
this is the definition of context so
you're saying this is just a definition
no but it's it's what we need to know is
what do we do in science all the time we
try to have rigid definitions we try to
have rigid um criteria
you know when we think about
simple laws like f is equal to m a okay
etcetera i'm willing to accept that's
i'm even willing to accept that's a
scientific definition of contact even
when you were doing that analogy for me
you kept the balls apart you didn't make
the balls touch each other but the
important thing yeah but the the the
issue here is what we mean by contact
okay so right so what do you science or
is this are we just talking about words
and definitions here
i guess you know those two things are
always intrinsically entangled you know
definitions and what we mean and what
analogies we use and what models we use
how accurate are they my concern is this
idea of which is demonstrably wrong
demonstrating because we do this
measurement in the lab on a daily basis
we take one molecule up here we bring it
to another and we measure that force
directly and we can see where that force
turns around where that force goes to
zero due to this balance of the
attractive impulses once you reach this
point that you tell me is contact yep
can they move any closer if they move
closer they get a repulsive force in the
opposite direction that's the key thing
if they move closer they start to
experience repulsive force and if they
never came into contact we can measure
this directly hang on we can measure
this directly in the experiment we can
bring this one molecule in and we can
crush this one
how do you get atomic positions which
are changing
if you're crushing one molecule the
simple fact that you say once you reach
the contact point
if we move them even closer they start
repelling the simple fact that they can
even be moved closer but how do we just
says to me that they weren't encouraging
no but how do we define contact in this
case on the macroscopic world
right how do we bring this in we bring
it there
right so i can push down on it
but if at the point of contact right if
we try i really need a phil i don't
think anyone is arguing about the
definition of contact on the macroscopic
level everywhere right okay well that's
fantastic okay right so on the
microscopic level the thing that i find
concerning is the idea
that it's only electron repulsion
attraction is not mentioned even when
you've got what are called physical
interactions so not chemical
interactions this type of interaction
put my hand
as
right at the atomic and the molecular
level there is an attractive force there
before that repulsive force comes in and
it's the balance of those two forces
exactly so you know you've got something
falling under gravity right
okay so
we've got a reaction force from the
floor
you know how do you define contact in
this case it's we're basically just
scaling down that type of idea down to
the atomic level because why else would
we have another definition let me tell
you how how i feel about what you've
just said at the very start
you use the analogy of clapping hands
and you said some people say these two
hands have not come into contact
you said that's not true let me tell you
why
you then showed me this stuff about van
der waals force you showed me this this
magic point where
the two forces reach an equilibrium
and do you know what i took from that
my hands don't touch when i clap but
they get to this point where these
forces but what okay and they never
quite well let's no because the
repulsive then let's do this well then
let's define what you mean by touching
do you mean that the nuclear cores come
together do you mean that the nuclei
come because if so that's you know there
is really no point in discussion because
those energy scales are completely out
of reach we're not going to have if we
could have g's if we could have nuclear
fusion by doing that wonderful
it's about a question of how do you
define that contact point and my point
is that that point in science is pretty
well defined well what are the
fundamental quantities in physics energy
mass force etc and so if we're talking
about force so let's make a definition
on the balance of forces so you're much
more natural the definition of contact
the point where these two forces balance
out and we can't move the atom closer
yeah
no no i didn't say we can't move the
atom closer okay well then if we can
move the atom closer i argue they're not
in contact because that we could move
them closer right so let's go back to
this
let's go back to this are they in
contact
hang on are we are you talking about
them as footballs or atoms that's
footballs are they in contact yes all
right if i do that and i squeeze down on
that one right so that's exactly what's
happening when you push these in you get
a repulsive force but the important
thing is where do you you have to it's
not like we have a switch on it's not
like the forces switch on and switch off
instantaneously over very very small
ranges they they very smoothly i must
admit that's one definition you can have
other definitions of the contact point
yeah right so if it's a chemical bond
for example you could say right at the
point at which the overlap of the
electron density is such and such will
define that as the important thing is
that
the physics is such we can dress it up
in whatever mathematical language you
like but the physics is such that at the
atomic level
we have contact because otherwise why
would i
why would we call these techniques
non-contact and contact here's what i
think
here's a scientific definition of what i
think a normal person would think of as
contact between two particles
i think
and what all these normal what all these
analogies are trying to get at i think
true contact between two particles say
two electrons
is the point at which
the space occupied by the electron
could have no planck lengths
between it and the space occupied by
another electron
but a point where you could no longer
fit like the point of the electron has
zero planck lengths between the electron
to the right that fundament in quantum
mechanics you can never have that but
that's that's an extra yeah but that's
an extreme definition where would you
use that definition that's like saying
you're going to define contact as when i
overlap this football with the other one
and they occupy the same space that's
exactly what you're saying well when you
touched them they got to a point where i
could no longer put a piece of paper
between them and so they're in contact
for like on the mac but you're arguing
that if two electrons occupy the same
space not the same space there's just no
longer well the problem yeah but the
problem is you know from you've done
these videos over the years we cannot
define an electron like a particle like
that so i think that's why things can't
come yeah so therefore the analogy and
my point again is the analogy breaks
down and you've got to come up you've
got to use a scientific definition that
everybody can agree with i agree it has
clear delineation points which is very
helpful for a definition
and if that's the definition you want
that's fine but i think your definition
of contact your scientific definition of
contact the point where force x and
force y come into balance
isn't what the normal purpose but the
problem is you can't extend what the
normal person thinks about touching down
to the quantum level so you have to come
up with another definition your analogy
breaks down analogy entirely breaks down
because you cannot extend it down to the
quantum level so when people make these
videos or have these discussions that
upset you where they say things don't
contact what i think they're doing
is these people have realized
the wonder of what's going on at this
microscopic but they have to get the
physics right let me finish okay sorry
sorry they've realized the wonder of
what's happening at this nano level and
a really good way to convey the wonder
of that is to say do you know what these
things aren't even touching i agree i
agree but you have to be careful to the
extent to which you overplay that new
hybrid this is the important thing and
it's it's true not just in terms of
public engagement in terms of of youtube
videos and
education via via online uh channels etc
it's true also in terms of the science
we do it's very easy for us to over hype
our results and and and give them a
connection to the
real world that might not be justified
you've got to be very careful when you
put analogies across to explain what the
deficiencies might be in those analogies